i
[Música]
a
un estudio presentado en el verano aquí
en alemania confirmó lo que muchos
padres de familia ya habían podido
determinar en sus propios hogares que
los menores de edad están pasando cada
vez más tiempo en redes sociales o con
juegos en línea en particular durante
los cierres temporales de los colegios
en el momento más álgido de la crisis de
coronavirus aquí en alemania el estudio
explicó que el tiempo promedio que
pasaron los menores entre 10 y 17 años
en redes sociales aumentó en un 66% en
días laborales en comparación con otros
periodos y el estudio añadió que el
aumento en el caso de los juegos en
línea es incluso mayor la comisionada
del gobierno alemán para estos temas
describió el aumento de grave explicó
que la tendencia debe frenarse que sobre
todo es necesaria una mejor educación
mediática para que los menores puedan
determinar los tiempos adecuados para
pasar en línea
[Música]
en ese ahora comenzado el año escolar
2020 y 2021 a la modalidad online según
el decreto del mandatario nicolás maduro
con este método no presencial padres y
representantes tienen que ingeniárselas
para no paralizar la enseñanza de sus
hijos y que continúen aprendiendo se
enfrentan a varios factores externos que
impiden a los niños educarse como es
debido entre ellos la falta de
electricidad en muchas regiones del país
y una precaria conexión a internet
debido al deficiente servicio que presta
la compañía nacional cantv también hay
otra parte de la población muy pobre que
no cuenta ni con teléfonos inteligentes
ni computadoras para acceder a las
plataformas de estudio nicolás madura en
varias ocasiones le ha pedido el
organismo regulador de
telecomunicaciones conatel de instalar
internet en centros educativos y liceos
y mejorar la conectividad de los hogares
también ha pedido enseñar las clases de
primaria y secundarias a través de la
señal abierta de distintos canales de
televisión del estado para llegar a
quienes no cuentan con tecnología
[Música]
la pandemia del gobi 19 afectando
gravemente el sistema educativo
hondureño de acuerdo a estudios
realizados por organizaciones de la
sociedad civil un aproximado de 1.5
millones de niños y jóvenes se están
quedando sin acceso a la educación por
la implementación de la educación online
a raíz de la suspensión de las clases
presenciales para evitar la propagación
de la pandemia y es que de los 9 puntos
3 millones de hondureños sólo el 16.6
por ciento tiene acceso al internet en
sus hogares para mitigar esta situación
el ministerio de educación implementó el
programa te queremos estudiando en casa
que consiste en la impartición de clases
a través de la radio y la televisión y
para todos aquellos niños que viven en
zonas aisladas en zonas rurales y que
son de escasos recursos económicos de
acuerdo al ministro de educación se les
ha hecho llegar material didáctico y se
les hace una evaluación cada 15 días
pese a estas medidas los expertos
afirman que es necesario y urgente
y un programa de educativo que sea
inclusivo y que además sea eficiente
para que los hondureños el próximo año
reciban una educación de mayor calidad
[Música]